so
[Music]
this form of picture thinking
constitutes the specific mode in which
spirit in this community becomes aware
of itself
this form is not yet spirit
self-consciousness that has advanced to
its notion quan notion the mediation is
still incomplete
this combination of being and thought is
therefore defective in that spiritual
being is still burdened with an
unreconciled split into a here and a
beyond
the content is the true content but all
its moments when placed in the medium of
picture thinking have the character of
being uncomprehended in terms of the
notion of appearing as completely
independent sides which are externally
connected with each other
before the true content can also receive
its true form for consciousness a higher
formative development of consciousness
is necessary it must raise its intuition
of absolute substance into the notion
and equate its consciousness with with
its self-consciousness for itself just
as this has happened for us or in itself
in paragraph 765 we have a bit more
discussion of this mode of picture
thinking or for stellang that is not
going to be
quite adequate although it's felt at the
time to be in advance and to be more
adequate but it's not yet
conceptual it's not yet
notion
it's not the fully developed notion that
we're looking for
in the religious community in the
revealed religion
so hegel talks about this this form of
picture thinking constituting the
specific mode
in which spirit
in this community now notice we're
talking about the importance of the
community which is a mediation that is
taking place not just at one point in
time but also through time over
generations right
becomes aware of itself and this is the
the main goal right in the entire
religion section and throughout the
phenomenology not becoming aware of
itself in its inception but becoming
more fully aware of itself becoming
aware of itself in the
way that will be adequate to what it is
that human being is
and what spirit
can be so he tells us that this form is
not yet spirit
self-consciousness
that has advanced to its notion qua
notion right the grief alts
and so we have a not yet here but we
have something on the horizon that we're
definitely
moving towards right we're making some
progress towards it and part of this
progress is realizing
that there's a problem here we're going
to get to that in just a moment so he
says the mediation
is still
incomplete it's not been brought to its
fulfillment so we've got two different
modes for spirits
self-consciousness
mediated through the community
worked out in the community we've got
this not yet notion as notion and we'll
come back to that in just a bit because
we have to elaborate the other side now
this form of picture thinking for
stalin's right
and here you know it's the the verbal
for stalin
picture thinking
representing this in in in activity you
could say although foreshadowing
although it can refer to the
representation
as the product represented it also has
to do with the representing
as well
so what does he tell us
there is a
problematic here
and
it has to do with this combination the
fair binding
between being and thought and you notice
that now we're no longer
in this paragraph talking about some of
the other things like existence we're
talking about design not design thought
though is is really you know central to
this thought is driving the entire
process
and
now the the text is a little bit it
loses a little bit of the sense of
what's going on here
because he says this combination this
fair binding of being in thought is
therefore defective
now
defective is an adjective and it
describes a
certain lack or a failure or a marring
or something like that
and here in hegel's german we have
mongol and and you know that can be
translated you could translate that as
defect um a lack um you know destitution
it's a privative term something has gone
wrong something's missing
something ought to be there that isn't
and so we have a defect in this
combination
what's the defect well
hegel goes on to tell us
what this consists in and it's got a
couple different
interconnected modalities right he says
it's spiritual being is still burdened
with an unreconciled split right so
a you know
enzyme is split but it's a
becoming two
that are now apart from each other
a unreconciled
uh split
into
a here and a beyond where have we seen
this well the unhappy consciousness
right that was the thematic of the
unhappy consciousness here and not there
there that we could get to a beyond that
we never actually get to
so
you know
what do we what can we say about this
hegel tells us that these are two
completely independent sides now they're
completely independent in our
minds at this point in what the
community is representing to itself in
the
representation are they really
completely independent sides in reality
no there's mediation going on but it is
a mediation that is not being adequately
thought out and lived out
so these are treated as being
externally connected with each other and
you know if you go to
hegel's lectures on the philosophy of
religion you'll see him talking about
foreshadowing as you know problematic in
this respect not only is there the image
and picture and stuff like that that
we're working with which is rather
conditioned
but this treatment as if ideas or our
concepts or notions are really just
building blocks that we put together
hegel says that that is to be identified
with philosophies of the understanding
but here it's also the way in which the
religious community is understanding
itself in relation to
its
object right so the religious community
now has you know had somebody walking
among them teaching
loving eating hugging doing all the
things that people do and it turned him
into a
beyond right and so he he goes on and he
says before the true content
and we should we do have to come back to
this the content is the true content he
says so we've got something to work with
right but it's moments uh have the
character of being uncomprehended and
here there's a bit of a
addition in terms of the notion but
that's fine because being uncomprehended
means
not being in the form of the notion you
know
not being
or in this term the verb gyphen right
they are not yet comprehended and that
is what we're trying to get to so
a little bit lower he says before the
true content can also receive its true
form so we're looking now at something
that's not the form of picture thinking
but the form of notion
a higher formative development of
consciousness is necessary something
more has to happen right we need to
proceed
and he says it must raise its intuition
on xiaomi of absolute substance
into the notion
so we have to we have to draw what we've
got
and put it into a conceptual
form there has to be a sublation taking
place here
and he says and equate its consciousness
with its self-consciousness for itself
just as this has happened for us or in
itself so we're seeing the for itself
and in itself being brought together
self-consciousness and consciousness
being brought together in the notion
again this is what in the very early
parts of the religion section
hegel was saying
needed to happen
and now we're actually getting to see it
not happening yet but at least on the
cusp of happening
because the problematic has been
identified and now we'll see where we go
from from here
this content is to be considered as it
exists in its consciousness absolute
spirit is the content and is thus in the
shape of its truth
but its truth is not to be merely the
substance or the in itself of the
community not merely to step forth out
of this inwardness into the objectivity
of picture thinking but to become an
actual self to reflect itself into
itself and to be subject
this therefore is the movement which it
accomplishes in its community or this is
the life of the community
consequently what this self-revealing
spirit is in and for itself is not
elicited by as it were unraveling the
rich life of spirit in the community and
tracing it back to its original strands
to the ideas say of the primitive
imperfect community or even to the
utterances of the actual man it's
himself
this tracing back is based on the
instinct to get to the notion but it
confuses the origin of the notion as the
immediate existence of its first
manifestation with the simplicity of the
notion
what results from this impoverishment of
spirit from getting rid of the idea of
the community and its action with regard
to its idea
is not the notion but rather bear
externality and singularity the
historical manner of the manifestation
in its immediacy and the non-spiritual
recollection of a supposed individual
figure
and of its past
paragraph
766 further elaborate some mistaken
approaches to
understanding the revelation that is
happening in revealed religion
and how it relates to spirits in the
community in the gomanda
which includes us if we are
looking on and trying to get out of that
historical community and its development
and its hermeneutics what it is that we
can draw
from it we're not completely
disconnected from it even if we you know
look at it from the vantage point of
late modernity and its secularity if
hegel's right there's something that
happens at least in the west through
christianity
and he's going to talk about
self-revealing
orphan barranda
spirit right so he says that we're going
to look at this
conscious we're going to look at
consciousness and this content that we
started discussing in the previous
paragraph this content is to be
considered as it exists in its
consciousness absolute spirit
is the content and thus in the is thus
in the shape of its truth so we're going
to come to that in a
moment right and he says the truth is
not merely to be this or that so we're
going to go into that so a little bit
later he says what this self-revealing
spirit is
in and for itself is not going to be
gotten at in in one way that we're going
to come to in a moment so what what is
this right we've got the in and for
itself on and for zeke uh it's not on
infrasign it's as this spirit is in
itself and for itself and so that's you
know an important unity but as we've
seen it's it's a not yet right
and we're going to get a little bit more
description of what that
not yet is going to
look like and rather abstract terms in
just a moment
but
we've also got this aspect of
self-revealing
offenbaranda right so a revealer reveals
to a
revel you know revelee we could say as
opposed to the revealed what is it
that's being revealed it's not just a
bunch of words or well here's the truth
of everything in propositional form
it rather has to do with the relations
between the revealer
and the revealed two the reveal e we
could say
and so the revealed
what has been you know made
open orphan barn is
not just a
set of dogmas or you know practices or
something do this and you'll be right
with god
it's rather
a better understanding of the nature of
god and our relation with god right
so how does this take place
well we've got this content this in halt
of the absolute spirit and when we see
this term content we should immediately
think well what's the form
form and content go together and here's
where he talks instead of form
he uses the term gestalt the shape
the shape of absolute spirit
here
he says it's thus in the shape of its
truth it's var height
it's
condition of being true and then he says
it's truth and here we have a
not just so he's not saying
that
these other things
are going to be completely left behind
get rid of them they're no good
whatsoever
he is saying that they're not only not
the entire picture
but they're not the main show
even though there's a tendency to think
of them as being the main show at this
point so we've got three things that are
being
mentioned here
what do we have the truth is not merely
to be the substance
or the in itself of the community the
commander right
it's not just the
community itself
associated people you know bridging time
all of that
okay but it's not not that the community
does matter right we don't leave the
community behind because one of the
fundamental mistakes as we're going to
see is pretending like we're part of
some original you know
urshbrong community
which we're not we're part of a
community that has been in the process
of understanding and transforming itself
in relation to this revealed religion
right so that's the first thing
then he says
nor merely to step forth out of this
inwardness the inwardness of the
community into the objectivity the gag
and stanley kite of picture thinking
okay that is the
um objectivity the object-likeness of
the picture thinking the forstellens
of the
community the community has been given
this revelation the community is
thinking about it it is depicting it it
is arranging it it is presenting it
right and who is it presenting it well i
guess to you know potential members of
the community as it does missionary
activity but much more to itself
over time these are good these are
advances but they're not the whole show
and it's a mistake to think of them as
being so both for those who would take
on that religion and for those who would
reject or criticize that religion
because they're missing out on
something that's
in hegel's view much more important at
this stage
what is this
okay it's truth it's var height
is to become an actual
self
vehicle
right so a self that is not merely a
negative a self that exists
within the world is vehicle is real is
actual as a member of the community
within the community right but as a self
and this self
is
to be subject
subject in the sense of agency
right so how does this happen he says it
reflects itself into
itself now that is a very interesting
way to think about it
reflects itself into itself
right the zelps
reflect
right and thereby becomes subject the
self attains a you could say greater
intensity with this inward reflection
of itself by itself in itself
and it doesn't do so
entirely in a solipsistic way making
itself god
it does so in relation to what has been
revealed i mean we are not that far at
this point in talking about this from
one of hegel's great critics
cern kierkegaard if you ever read the
beginning of the sickness on to death
what is the self it is a relation that
is you know related to a relation it
gets quite complex that is reflection
that is being reflected into itself and
in relation to god
so we got a lot going on here in terms
of the truth right the truth is not
something simple not something to be
simplified and that is going to be a
fundamental mistake that so many
religious people
make in in christianity and you could
also extend this to other religions
so he says to us
this therefore is the movement
which it accomplishes in its community
or this is the life of the community so
this
reflection of the self into itself the
actual self
becoming subject doesn't take place by
somebody withdrawing entirely from the
community but through their
participation
in the community they could become a
sort of privileged point within the
community oh i've had these you know new
ideas about these revelations and what
they mean for us let me write a book you
know let me teach people let me become a
saint all of those are possibilities but
they exist within a community
so he goes on and he says
consequently what this self-revealing
spirit is in and for itself is not
elicited by
unraveling the rich life of spirit in
the community notice
rich life for spirit
is possible within a community
it doesn't mean that you have to be like
looking at everybody all the time or
going to services all the time
community extends throughout space and
time and it might exist partly in your
imagination right in your connection
with others who are long past again if
we want to use kierkegaard think about
who he views himself as as uh in
conversation with and as connected with
well hegel for one but also luther also
descartes also augustine all these other
people that are long since past
so
being within the rich life of the
community that is a possibility for
spirit how do we lose that how do people
lose that
taking the wrong path
engaging in something that becomes
you know if we want to use hegel's terms
something that's supposed to be vehicle
something that's supposed to be actual
but is actually just for gestelt
something just purely represented or
even imagined right and this happens a
lot in the history of christianity and
not just with the protestant reformation
and the many different sects that and
movements that emerge from that where
we're going to get back to the original
church right and they never do get back
to the original church they just
generate new
new versions of contemporary churches
that are
baggaged with all of this
ideology of uh pretending to be original
right pretending to go back to the the
origin point this happened within
catholicism as well
this happens you can also say in the
struggle between orthodoxy and heresy
right so he goes on and he says
it's not um
elicited
by unraveling the rich life of spirit in
the community and tracing its back to
its original strands it's fought in it's
it's you know little chords uh as a
matter of fact if you want to use that
metaphor what you're going to find when
you pull on these chords is you unravel
everything and you make a mess of it
right and then you try to weave it back
together but you've got a mess instead
rather than anything that has a texture
anything that has
staying power so he goes on and he says
what are these these you know things you
could trace to the ideas of for example
the primitive
imperfect community right the
unfolded right the the undeveloped
community there's all these people
throughout uh
time who've been like we just got to get
back to the origin of the early church
and you know gotta gotta like see what
things were like for them and he said
well where are you gonna get that from
oh well you're the bible right and
you're like well
you gotta understand that biblia there's
no bible by the way in the singular
there's top biblio the books and if you
like read through you know early
christian thinkers you're going to see
them actually talking about these books
as if they were separate collections
which in fact they were right so we
don't want to have this naive
quasi-fundamentalist
idolatrous attitude towards the early
church and towards the scriptures that
are somehow going to reveal it i mean
the source documents don't tell us a
hell of a lot unless we start adding in
patristic things you know like looking
at what the early christians actually
had to say and if we make this this
fundamental schism between uh the holy
scripture of the bible and all these
other writings that you know get called
tradition within the earlier churches
like you know the orthodox and the
eastern
further east churches and the catholic
church well then we we lose the early
community
the primitive
imperfect community
is not the full development of
christianity for hegel right um you know
in hegel you could say well hegel's a
lutheran you know they're more uh
conservative protestants they held on to
a lot of that tradition stuff and hegel
would say yeah we didn't throw the baby
out with the bath water you know uh we
we actually held on to what these other
people have lost through their naivety
they're thinking that like they're gonna
be the center of reforming uh this this
vast religion
or we could also go to the utterances of
the actual man himself this jesus christ
guy what did he have to say again
where do we get these you know through
the
documents that we call the gospels
primarily right
and
then you know through
we could say the mind of the community
engaging with those seeing what they
actually have to say i suppose you could
say you could think of a pre-christian
jewish texts insofar as they're supposed
to be talking about this guy
in an allegorical way
uh you know the psalms or isaiah or
things like that but you know
that's
let's say there's a lot of
interpretation involved there and hegel
says this
is an impoverishment
of spirit
this is actually taking the revelation
that is being made
and whittling it down to
the you know the the confines of
the
human beings that think that they're on
to something with going back to this
this early
church and early community and he says
this tracing back is based on the
instinct a good instinct to get to the
notion the grief but it confuses
the origin the urshbong of the notion as
the immediate existence of its first
manifestation with the simplicity
the developed simplicity of the notion
so you get an impoverishment of spirit
why
you're getting rid of the idea the
forest telling
of the community and its action with
regard to its idea so it's not just
making ideas or you know continuing
replicating ideas
the community engages in action
doing
with these ideas
and it develops them further getting
them closer and closer to something
that's not just
for stellar not just ideas not just
picture thinking
by contrast if we try to go this i'm
going to get to the early church and i
i'm the one who actually knows what that
means you know because i'm so smart and
i you know
i can read the the scriptures and
they'll tell me so easily what it is you
know
we've all encountered people like that
hegel says this is bare externa
externality and singularity the
historical manner of the manifestation
in its immediacy and the non-spirit
recollection of a supposed individual
figure and of its past
non-spiritual
there's something
less human
about this i'm going back here and and
all the rest of you are wrong everybody
else who's thought about this throughout
history because i'm you know i'm so
smart i'm so pious i have a privileged
position
ignoring the vast sweep of the action of
the community many of whom are smarter
than us i mean just spend some time
reading patristic authors and you'll be
like wow these people really knew a lot
and thought very deeply about this i'm
kind of uh you know
not very far along the learning curve
compared to them you know so
hegel is telling us that that is the the
way in which we have to understand the
truth
of absolute spirit here in
revealed religion and we want to avoid
these reductive ways of understanding
the community and its representation or
going back to the origin points
in some attempt to get at the real
notion
that hasn't yet been developed there
of this revealed religion
you